للاسبوع الثاني على التوالي مشاهدينا
بنستمر معاكم في نقل تطورات وتبعات
الزلزال اللي ضرب سوريا وتركيا الاثنين
الماضي عزل القتلى في كل البلدين تجاوز 35
الف قتيل ومئات الالاف من الجرحى وملايين
من المشردين والهزات الارتداديه ما انتهت
فمن وقت الزلزال لليوم وصل عدد الهزات
الارتداديه اللي رسلت في تركيا بس
1891 هزه من بينها عدد من الهزات سجلت
صباح اليوم هذا غير عشرات الزلازل اللي
ضربت سوريا وتركيا وبدرجات قوه متفاوته
فسمعنا عن زلازل شرك وغرب ووسط تركيا
وزلازل على الحدود السوريه اللبنانيه وغرب
مدينه اللاذقيه السوريه واعلن المركز
الاوروبي المتوسطي للزلازل عن 500 زلزال
ضربوا مناطق حول العالم بتتجاوز قوتها
اربعه درجات على مقياس رختر ومن وقت زلزال
الاثنين الماضي وسيره كل الناس هي الزلازل
وامكانيه التنبؤ فيها فبدايه شفنا باحث
هولنديل وتغريده متنبئه بالزلزال واماكن
وقوعه قبل ما يقع بثلاثه ايام وبعدها
علماء قالوا صدفه وكذب والتنبؤ ممكن ولكن
رجعوا طلعوا علماء ثانيين وقالوا الا ممكن
التنبؤ فطلع الباحث الهولندي من جديد يوم
الجمعه في فيديو على يوتيوب وخوف الناس
اكثر وتوقع زلزال جديد كبير في لبنان ومصر
والسبب انه تاريخها البلدين عرضه للزلازل
الكبرى لكن اكد انه لا يمكن التنبؤ بوقت
حدوثه لكن اكيد الزلزال جاي
[موسيقى]
وكان
عبد الله العمري اهلا فيك معانا
اول شيء خلينا يعني نحسب موضوع جدل التنبؤ
بالزلازل هل يمكن التنبؤ بالزلازل ولا لا
يمكن
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اشكر قناه العربيه
حقيقه
هذا حقيقه اذا كان دول المتقدمه واللي لها
باع كبير في هذا المجال الولايات المتحده
واليابان عندما ياسوا من مساله التنبا
نهائيا اتجهوا الى ما يسمى ببرامج تخفيف
المخاطر الزلزاليه يصرفون بنين الدولارات
اليابان يحصل فيها يوميا سبعه الاف هزه
ومع هذا تنبؤ بالزلزال في الشمال الغربي
وقع في الجنوب الشرقي انتهى الموضوع
التنبؤ في علم الغيب اولا بعد اراده الله
سبحانه وتعالى لا يمكن التنبؤ بتبع ممكن
بالاحوال الجويه ممكن الظروف المناخيه
لانها وتشوفها وتشوف المعين وتعمل لها
ماشيه ومحاكه وانتهى الموضوع لكن بالنسبه
للباطل الارض فيه متغيرات كثيره لعرض 50
وستين كيلو سرعه مختلفه جاذبيه مختلفه
تركيب كيميائي تركيب كيميائي حراره ضغط
مختلفه المعايير جدا مختلفه فبالتالي ما
تقدر حتى موضوع العمق الان موضوع عمق
البلدان مستحيل مرصد من المراتب اللي
تعطيك تركيا كل 15
نقول 12
تقول لك 13 كيلو العمق يعني له ثلاثه كيلو
مستحيل وبالتالي كيف تقدر انت تقولي هذا
التوقع نعم اتوقع زلزال معين في عالم
الفلاني بعد سنه سنتين متوقع مثل ما ذكرنا
الخبير الهولندي صحيح كلامه لكن اذا قال
لك اتنبا معناه انا بحدد لك الساعه
الفلانيه بعد ثلاثه ايام او على ضوء اعمل
اخلاء
صراحه يعني في تغريدته بتقول
الدول الشرق المتوسط عملنا منظمه تحت
اليونسكو ونجتمع سنويا 25 اجتماع عملناه
الى الان وكلنا بالاجماع كل انا نقول
الفارق البحر الميت الين تركيا ولانا
تتعرض لجلدان عنيف كل مره بشكل ما فيها
نقاط لكن ما استطعنا نحدد متى يحصل هذا
الزلزال طيب نعم بالنسبه لتوقف
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للتوابع والهندسه الابتداديه صحيح
لماذا لان الزل
البحر الميتان قادم في خلال السنوات
القادمه بناء على ايه لان عندي سجل جلجالي
الى 2000 سنه للاردن وسوريا ومصر بقدر
احدد كم الفتره الزمنيه ممكن يحصل زلزال
تبع درجات في المنطقه الفلانيه مثلا في
اريحا حتى العام 1927 كان قاتل اللي فيها
ايه
كذا في سوريا حصل كذا في الخليج عام 1995
وهكذا عندنا تسلسل جاني نعرف بالضبط على
المطلع
اللي حصلت عليه الدلالك تتكرر تتكرر تتك
لكن اقواها ترى في الشمال ليه في الشمال
لانه هناك ثلاث صفائح تلتقي مع بعض
العربيه واليوراثيه والاناضوليه مع بعضها
تاكيد المنطقه اكثر عرضه من غيرها ثم تبدا
تقل اقل واقل جهه لبنان وسوريا والبحر
ثم لعربه ما في شيء ثم ترجع ثاني مره في
خليج العقبه وهكذا طيب
عفوا عفوا عفوا بعدين نروح الاقوى الاقوى
والاقوى جهه ايران جهه ايران منطقه اقتصاد
وفي جبال جاك هذا عريف هنا كان طيب بس
وبالنسبه لرئيس اداره الجيولوجيين
السعوديين الدكتور عبد العزيز اللعبوني
اللي قال انه فيها هزه ارضيه ممكن تحصل في
عمق البحر الاحمر هذا الكلام ايش رايك فيه
البحر الاحمر
موضوع اخر البحر الاحمر لا يقضي على اللي
حصل في تركيا وهذا البحر الاحمر تشكل تشكل
قبل عشرين مليون سنه ثم هناك متشكر في
صدوع وفوالق والزلازل اللي في البحر
الاحمر
سته وتحصل سبعه لكنها ضعيفه لان الزلازل
واقعه في البحر الاحمر ناتجه عن عمليه شد
وليست عن عمليه تحول الشد غير مثل ما يعني
كل الارضيه
رايحين جنوب غرب في اي جاء يح
صل ترى
يختلف بعد عن بعضها فلذلك هذا كلام يعني
مستبعد شويه كلام انه يحصل دردار في البحر
الاحمر بتاثير او يؤثر على البنيه التحتيه
في المملكه لا صحيح لو قلت خليج العقبه
اقرا لان خليج العقبه مربوط بالبحر الميت
لكن
من البحر الاحمر شمال وانت جايه جنوب هذا
حد
زلزال مختلف عن اللي ذكرناه فيها مختلف
طيب خليني بس استفيد من وجودك معايا
والوقت والموضوع الهزات
والارتدادات والامور هذه كلها يعني من يوم
الاثنين هيئه الكوارث التركيه بتقول انه
حتى الان صار فيه 240 او عفوا 2040 400 بس
اذا اكدوا لي الرقم يا جماعه 2400 ايوه
بالفعل هزه ارتداديه يعني هذا الكلام
حيستمر لمتى وهذا مزيد من الدمار واللي
يعني
اللي حصل الله يسلمك خليها اصحح بمصطلح
اكثر من كذا الارتداليه
ايش معنى حشود زلزاليه
توصل الفين ثلاثه
وخاصه وخاصه اذا كانت المنطقه فيها
بركانيه من اول فيها صخور بركانيه وخاصه
اذا عندك في تركيا السبب وجود السدود
والمنطقه مليانه بالمويه وجود المياه تعمل
استحساس وتعمل تحفيز للمنطقه للعديد من
الهزات لكن ليس لها تاثير قوي لكنها تقعد
تستمر تستمر لكن ليست مخيفه مثل ما حصل
يوم الاحد الماضي عفوا شفتي كيف فبالتالي
هذه حتى تستمر حتى تنتهي الطاقه ننتقل من
مكان لمكان من شمال الاناضوري الى شرق
الى سوريا الى مصر الى
لكن انتهي نهائيا والحدود ادا
ه مفيده زلزاليه وليست لحظه وليست
ارتداديه الحشود غير
مثلا اعطيك مثل
[موسيقى]
كان اربعه ونص
قالتنا سته اشهر رصدنا 15 الف
في الاسبوع الاول لان الزناجر اللي بتحكي
الاسبوع الاول
الرئيسيه بمقدار درجه الى درجه يعني هو
بكره يكون عدى اسبوع خلاص على الحدث بس
يعني انا حسيتك كانك بتحاول انه تقول لنا
انه يعني ان شاء الله خير ما في شيء نعم
نعم نعم
وحتى لو حصلت اي شيء
اقل المنطقه الاقوى هي اللي وقعت فيها
الدجال اللهم اجبر مصابهم اللي ايش لانه
حصل في خلال هذه المنطقه اللي انا تكلمت
عنها فيها خلال من 1939 الى امس حصل فيها
15 زلزال عنيف ومدمر
ومدمر لاحظي يعني كل
[موسيقى]
حتى التصميم المنطقه اللي حصل فيها
الحمد لله الان الامور مطمنه ولكن ترى
جلدان بنفس القوه لا
بعدين ايش السبب لان منطقه الاردن
فلسطين والبعض في منطقه البحر الميت عباره
عن الصفيحه العربي
وصفيحه هنا تتجه الجنوب الغربي ما في
تصادم ما في تصادم في عمليتين احتكاك فقط
يعني ان شاء الله
فلسطين ولا الاردن ان شاء الله
البنيه التحتيه تحتاج الى تدعيم وكود
الهندسي الزلزاني في الاردن وفلسطين لابد
انه يؤخذ في الاعتبار وجامعه النجاح وقدر
لها الكلام هذه اللي اشتغلت شغل جيد في
هذا الموضوع فبالتالي لابد حقيقه انه
مصرين على تطبيق كود البناء للمباني
المقامه حاليا والمباني اللي يعادلها
اعاده تاهيل والمباني التي سوف تقام او
المنشات مستقبلا لابد تؤخذ بالاعتبار له
المواصفات الهندسيه ولا يرفعون المباني
الى اكثر من اربعه خمسه ادوار ابدا ما هي
المنطقه اللي فيها نشاط لازم المباني
العاليه تسبب اشكاليه ترى الترددات يعني
سلامتك الله يسلمك وانا بشكرك على وجودك
معانا وعلى كل هذه المعلومات كان معنا
رئيس الجمعيه السعوديه ليه علوم الارض
والمشرف على مركز الدراسات الزلزاليه في
جامعه الملك سعود البروفيسور عبد الله
العمري شكرا لك
[موسيقى]